Ever been bothered by an ultra-slow download?
How about a phone that won’t stay charged
or a cracked touchscreen?
Imagine you were stranded on an island with
nothing to drink.
What if science came up with a way to solve
all these problems with a single chemical
compound that you can find, of all places,
in a pencil?
A thousand gigabytes in one second.
A smartphone fully charged in 5.
Superthin, flexible, and unbreakable touchscreens.
And a personal saltwater filter.
All this and more is possible with the Nobel
prize-winning material graphene.
As early as the 1940s, theoretical studies
predicted graphene to have high levels of
electrical conductivity, thermal conductivity,
and breakage strength.
Graphene was also known to compose the subunits
of the common material graphite, found in
a pencil.
Draw a line and groups of graphene flakes,
comprised of carbon atoms arranged in a honeycomb
array, slide onto the paper, producing a mark.
The problem was that no one could figure out
how to isolate a single flake.
Scientists tried various chemical means, resulting
in nothing more than graphitic sludge.
Mechanical polishing got them to 0.001 mm
of graphite, but that was still about 1000
layers of graphene.
In 2002, a group from the University of Manchester
took a more “MacGyverist” approach.
Using their self-dubbed “Scotch-tape method”,
physicists Sir Andre Geim and Sir Konstantin
Novoselov peeled away at a graphite crystal,
producing flakes that became vanishingly thin.
An atomic force microscope revealed their
success.
The elusive material finally in hand, scientists
were able to see just what graphene could
do.
As predicted, it’s an excellent electrical
conductor.
The free electron on each carbon atom in graphene
enables movement of charge across the surface.
Moreover, it’s thermal conductivity, or
ability to transfer heat, is higher than that
of copper.
Mechanically, the strong bonds between carbon
atoms and the inherent stability of a hexagonal
array combine to produce the strongest material
known to man.
Nonetheless, the bonds of graphene retain
remarkable flexibility.
As a sprayable, two-dimensional surface, it
can be used to easily tune the properties
of other compounds.
A lot of people are excited about graphene’s
possible versatile applications.
Because graphene has very high conductivity
and is almost completely transparent, it could
be used to make more efficient electronics.
These electronics have the potential to be
more environmentally safe once graphene extraction
techniques are improved.
With its high breakage strength, graphene
could be the key to lighter and stronger building
materials.
New techniques for creating nano-scale pores
in sheets of graphene indicate that it could
be used to make ultra-thin filters.
As scientists think up new ways to use this
supermaterial, it’s worth recalling its
humble entry into the scientific world.
Using a piece of scotch tape and a block of
pencil lead, two scientists were able to make
a groundbreaking discovery.
In 2010, the Royal Swedish Academy of Sciences
awarded Geim and Novoselov the Nobel Prize
in Physics for their efforts.
Together, they proved that scientific innovation
does not always require fancy instrumentation;
it requires persistence and creativity.